[Music]
the spaniards had not arrived to
conquer mexico but we already have
our meals and we already have how to
cook we are already thousands of years old
the food is us and we
are the food 1 cook with the soul and
with the spirit
[Music]
this  project also indigenous group
living guajaca mexico eleven trading
civilization the textile worker himself
agent coverage baby macho life
insulting apple have abigail mendoza
good mexicans regarding the cers right
now we are here my
restaurant called la manada
I cook with one of my sisters the
others are  learning the table but
we are among sisters all meaningless
fire walk of fame forgiving ancestral in
traditional support with weezer culkin
alive
before the Spanish arrived here
our ancestors used stones
found in a beautiful stone and look for
another stone to form a metate
that  is what characterizes our food
the root of our tradition
the way  that I prepare my kitchen and
I prepare it in a natural way, manual
craftsmanship
and Avilés titles making the light of the
cherry the main one and how it is done
when you go out, they are given the
selections of the region with this
question if you are on twitter
if they tell them  the fruit of the intense physical
[Music]
originally our ancestors
sat on chairs to have the
contact of the earth towards them because
thanks to mother earth we have food
[Music]
this is a part of the
cultural education that is being lost because
all the  People are thinking about
materialism, they are no longer thinking about what
we ate before, how it nourishes us,
the meals that we prepare
manually, it is slower, but also
when you want your culture and when you
want your town, you keep that
part, I think
[Music]